the uk's ambassador to ukraine says her
return to kiev has been incredibly
emotional melinda simmons and her staff
were moved to live shortly after
russia's invasion began they returned on
friday and what she said was a
psychologically important move
this is my home for two and a half years
it's been my home and i've traveled this
country north south east and west of it
i've got to know incredibly well i know
many people who are fighting and i know
wives and children of people who are
fighting it's incredibly emotional for
me and also for my
british friends and colleagues
for me to be here it means an enormous
amount for me to be here and when you
see this country being ravaged and death
and destruction in so many places
what what goes through your mind when
you see all of that well we drove
through that of course because if you
take the car you come you know into key
of oblast then you can see just how hard
uh russia tried to take care of and also
just how quickly
the focus became on uh hitting civilians
and attacking civilians and that is
shock upon shock we passed you know
bombed out playgrounds bombed out
schools hospitals burned out trees
twisted metal in farmland so obvious
really that right from the beginning
this was about hitting the ukrainian
nation it wasn't just about taking out
the military capability and i think that
shock is really important to harness
because it all needs calling out and it
needs calling out in order to ensure
that this sustained justice becomes part
of the conversation that we have very
quickly